une zone d'accueil désertes des espaces
d'actualisation vide tous les services
de pôle emploi sont dématérialisés
depuis le début du confinement
les quelques 700 conseillers yvelinois
reste tout de même mobilisé 80 % de
demandes de conseiller sans sans
mobiliser soit en télétravail soit
mobilisables il travaille de chez eux
avec leurs propres moyens il appelle les
demandeurs d'emploi soit ils viennent en
agence mais pour des équipes très
réduite pour que le confinement soit
respectée aussi première mission a
assuré l'actualisation des situations
des demandeurs d'emploi yvelinois tout
cela à distance sans les accueillir dans
les centres à l'heure où je vous parle
les demandeurs d'emploi qui ont
l'habitude de ça de s'actualiser chez
nous 70% ont fait leur actualisation
nous avons passé dès la semaine dernière
plus de 2000 appels pour les informer et
les travailler sur la manne de la
meilleure façon de faciliter leur
actualisation
nous allons à partir de demain et de la
semaine prochaine rappeler tout ce
qu'ils n'ont pas n'ont pas fait pour
assurer d'ici le 15 avril de leur
actualisation ce qui permettra leur
payement autres tâches permettre la
poursuite des différentes démarches pour
un retour à l'emploi formation
préparation à l'entretien rédaction d'un
cv
toutes ces activités peuvent être
réalisées sur la plateforme internet
emploie store tous nos services on
s'organise aujourd'hui pour que nos
prestations et nous il nous aide soit
celle qu'on peut dématérialisée avec nos
prestataires avec nos partenaires vont
être dématérialisé on proposera nos
demandeurs d'emploi des accompagnements
à distance sur leur projet travaillent
sur leurs projets étaient des ateliers à
distance les services de pôle emploi
restent aussi mobilisées auprès des
entreprises afin d'assurer une
continuité dans l'accompagnement du
recrutement de certaines sociétés